notre invité patrick moriau bakambu et
du chercheur en droit public à
l'université paris saclay
bonjour et merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors on peut bien
sûr dresser un bilan de ses trois ans de
mouvement lequel fait besoin
bonjour le bilan du mouvement des gilet
jaune au bout des trois années à paris
si depuis l'apparition de ces mouvements
contestataires est plutôt mitigé dans le
sens où les objectifs principaux qui ont
conduit à l'apparition de ce mouvement
notamment la lutte contre la cherté de
la vie ainsi que l'impression d'avoir
une écologie plus compter les punitive
l'on parle comme ont disparu si on prend
seulement ces deux éléments le carburant
est aujourd'hui pratiquement au même
niveau que je dirais même plus dans
certains coins de la france qu'en
novembre 2018 et l'écologie punitive
cette impression d'écolo d'une avarie
l'écologie punitive par rapport à ceux
qui possèdent des véhicules diesel et
qui doivent se déplacer sur des longs
trajets dans la france périurbaines est
toujours aussi présente cette situation
en ce sens on dirait que l'écho et mes
revendications sont encore à tenir par
un d'autre part on peut dire qu'il ya
des efforts pour la satisfaction de
certaines maisons l'atténuation de la
cherté de la vie notamment avec des
mesures que le gouvernement tente de
mettre en oeuvre par le cheik inflation
ainsi que la maîtrise sont semble-t-il
du prix de carburant contribuer à dire
qu'il ya quand même une nette évolution
par rapport à la situation qu'on avait
dit entre nous pour vous vous estimez
qu'il ya un vrai changement en trois ans
après la naissance du mouvement que des
choses ont été faites en tout cas par le
gouvernement et par emmanuel navon qu'il
a peut-être entendu la colère populaire
il ya une dynamique qui est dans le chef
de du pouvoir céder comprendre que
désormais la france cela n'est plus
cette france qui était facile et qu'ils
essaient souvent les corps constitués
les corps intermédiaires agir mais la
france est aujourd'hui un pays où on
voit la signalétique sion qui ne marche
pas bien la population va pouvoir se
prendre en charge et pouvoir réagir
parce qu'on avait un problème au début
du quinquennat d'emmanuel mac ans et que
on avait pratiquement pas nos positions
il n'y avait pratiquement aucune force
capable de répondre à la légitimité du
suffrage quelle manière votre aversion
2017 or face à une politique qui n'avait
pratiquement pas de position ou
déforestation tirer est que les et les
syndicats c'est que les corps constitués
avait été mise au pas il fallait que la
population puisse sortir dans la rue et
réagit désormais le pouvoir quel mac ont
compris cela et machin tp sur les
blondes claque plateforme statham
parfois tâte le terrain essaye de voir
si la grogne va monter ou pas dans
certaines situations si on peut voir le
cas de la taxe ou de
l'impossible de l'admettre la mesure qui
avait été initiée sur les contrôles
techniques des motos
emmanuel macron les affairés d'un
rétropédalage et rangs pour éviter
d'avoir des contestations des motards à
l'époque où on devait encore passer les
parts des élections régionales et
départementales donc c'est une prise de
conscience de pelli une dynamique qui
s'est mise alors le mouvement pourrait
t'il rabattre les cartes de la campagne
électorale à quelques mois de la
présidentielle
oui c'est possible mais pour alléger les
jo ne sont de plus en plus plaisant et
puis quelques semaines j'ai tiré
depuis la fin de l'été on peut dire les
gilet jaune réapparaissent préoccupe les
rôles poids et la rue afin de montrer
qu'il faut compter avec eux dans cette
campagne électorale qui s'annonce
puisque c'est nous on n'a pas connu un
tel mouvement aussi
imposant aussi comment je peux dire avec
les effets politiques et sociaux aussi
important sans qu'on puisse avoir des
retombées au plan électoral jusqu'à la
légine et jaunes eux mêmes n'ont pas su
imposer le tempo dont les suffrages
qu'on a eu les mots comment les
élections européennes
des élections municipales les élections
régionales départementales mais à
l'élection présidentielle qui est
l'élection la plus importante en france
les gilets jaunes contentant de faire
entendre leur voix ce ne sera pas par un
candidat qui tenteraient de se présenter
comme des comptes de gilet jaune puisque
jusqu à la détente à toutes les
tentatives dans ce sens et samson
d'échouer mais ce sera plutôt dans
l'essence les pouvoir porter le message
du gilet jaune et leurs revendications
dans le cadre d'un programme électoral
et là il faut s'entendre c'est que il
faut s'y attendre
à ces gens des citations qui est sûre
sont prises en compte on peut en venir
aux actes de violence qui ont été
recensés pendant ces trois années un de
mobilisation et d'ailleurs on a des
images on dirait qu'il ya eu quelques
échauffourées un quelques petits
affrontements entre manifestants et
forces de l'ordre justement comment
jugez-vous la façon dont la police a
géré ces manifestations tous les samedis
on le rappelle
il ya eu des sérieuses critiques de la
gestion de ces manifestations par la
police du show tous les deux premières
années où la première année
particulièrement plusieurs dizaines des
personnels bonnier des personnes qui ont
vu qu'ils ont eut quitté mutinés on
croirait être dans un pays en voie de
développement une dictature mais on est
en france hélas et c'est qu'il y avait
plus et même le défenseur des droits et
même la commission européenne par des
français et européen des droits de
l'homme a condamné la france et a
demandé aux autorités défendent les
mesures qui s'imposent donc la gestion
des manifestations par la police pose
toujours problème mais il faut aussi
tenir compte du fait que la contestation
en france l'a jamais il contestation
purement pacifique et s'est depuis mes
65 et d'autres d'événements qu'on a
connu plus avant la commune de paris la
révolution peut même remonter jusqu'à la
révolution
les contestations en france ont toujours
été très violente parce que le peuple
français quand ils sont dans la rue et
il a l'impression d'être un petit peu
bafouée et un peuple qui se sent bafouée
pas seulement non compris mais pas
futsal le général de gaulle avait eu une
erreur de dire que je vous ai compris
non le peuple avait pas besoin qui sont
compris le peuple avait besoin de
retrouver son estime qu'est ce que font
les français c'est face à nice qui se
sentent bafoués voilà c'est ça le
problème et il faudra arriver à
comprendre c'est la la la colère du
peuple qui apparaît dans ces moments là
ainsi que la mesure adapté parce que les
peuples ne cherchera pas
remplacés sur les pensées ils sont allés
vont adopter la démocratie ils ont
compris le système démocratique la
république c'est l'essence même de la
france il faudrait pas les débats ce
tollé dans le sens de les considérer
comme une menace pour les institutions
mais plutôt des canaliser leur colère en
essayant de comprendre comment éviter
qu'il y ait des débordements qui
pourraient amener la population à réagir
avec colère ou avec réprimande en ce
sens
merci à vous d'avoir été en direct sur
arte france